Guten Tag, mein Name ist Kimas und Herr Arsten. Ich werde jetzt mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch durchführen.
Bitte, um Sie mir zu beachten, wenn etwas unklar ist. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Marie-Louise Handorf.
Marie-Louisa Handorf.
Handorf, ja.
Alles klar.
Könnte Sie bitte Vorname und Nachname und Nachsame buchstabieren?
Ja, der Vorname ist Marie-M-A-R-I-E.
Binde Strich.
Louise-L-U-I-S-E.
Ist klar.
Nachname?
Handorf, H-A-N-D-O-R-F.
Okay. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich bin 50 Jahre alt.
Wie schwer und wie groß sind Sie?
Ja, ich bin 178 und ich wiege 83 kg.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich habe ganz schlimme Bauchschmerzen,
so oben im Bauch.
Mehr rechts als links.
Die schmerzen bis in den Rücken und in die Schulter aus.
Mir ist unglaublich schlecht.
Ich kann nichts mehr essen.
Ich habe die Schmerzen nicht mehr.
Mir ist total heiß.
Ich habe Fieber.
Ich musste mich übergeben.
3-4 Mal musste ich mich übergeben.
Die Schmerzen sind krass.
Das kommt immer in so Wellen.
Dann kramft sich der ganze Bauch zusammen.
Das tut richtig doll weh.
Ich habe sie bemerkt.
Sieht ihr sie übergeben?
Ja, das war natürlich Essenfeste.
Es war aber auch ein bisschen Blut mit drin.
Das hat mir auch ein bisschen Angst gemacht.
Ich verstehe.
Ich habe sie übergeben.
Messen Sie Ihre Fieber?
Ja, ich habe die Temperatur gemessen.
Es war nicht so hoch.
Aber das war bei 38.
Wir erwachsenen Fiebern gar nicht mehr so hoch.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Ich habe sie übergeben.
Die Schmerzen sind sehr stark.
Sie sind wirklich sehr stark.
Ich bin nicht ziemlich zimpernisch.
Aber ich habe sie übergeben.
Haben Sie einen Medikament stakeholders?
Nein, ich habe nichts aufgenommen.
Ich habe sie bemerkt.
Ich habe sie übergeben.
Wir haben diese Schmerzen.
Eingenommen? Nee, ich habe nichts eingenommen.
Nein.
Brauchen Sie jetzt Schmerzmittel?
Nein, also das wird ja jetzt nicht ewig lange dauern und dann müssen wir hier gucken,
wie es weitergeht, ja.
Alles klar.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Schutulgang oder wassallassen?
Nein, eigentlich habe ich da keine Probleme, aber das, was mir tatsächlich aufgefallen ist,
dass der Urin jetzt die letzten Tage sehr dunkel aussah, also dunkler als normal.
Was meinen Sie dunkelüren?
Die Farbe war so dunkel?
Browns oder gelb?
Ja, also dunkles gelb oder relativ dunkel halt.
So, als ob man viel zu wenig getrunken hat.
Okay.
Ähm, ja, wann trätende, ähm, ich merke, zum Beispiel nach dem Essen oder in der Reihel?
Ja, nach dem Essen fing das an, genau, nach dem Essen fing das richtig an und ich habe das schon seit längerer Zeit, ja,
das ist immer mal wieder, wenn ich, wenn ich etwas sehr Fettiges gegessen habe, ja,
oder auch so Zucker und, also Kuchen mit Schlagsahne oder sowas, dann habe ich das schon mal gehabt,
dass es so ein bisschen geziebt hat im Bauch, aber jetzt gestern, ja, gestern Abend habe ich auch,
habe ich ordentlich Bratkartoffeln gemacht mit viel Speck getrannt und Öl und ja,
und also danach ging das so richtig los und, oh, ich fühle mich wirklich grauenvoll.
Alles klar.
Ähm, gibt es etwas linderte Schmerzen?
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen lindert?
Das die Schmerzen lindert?
Also, ich habe nicht so richtig etwas entdeckt, muss ich sagen.
Ich meine, ich habe heute Nacht versucht, so ein klein bisschen zu beschlafen.
Wenn man dann im Bett liegt, hat man ja das Gefühl so, ja, also dann, dann liegt man wenigstens, ja,
aber richtig viel besser geworden ist das eigentlich nicht.
Alles klar.
Ähm, haben Sie Aufstoßen oder Sortbrinnen?
Normalerweise eigentlich nicht, nee.
Alles klar.
Ich möchte ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Allgemeingesundheitsstelle.
Haben Sie Schuttefrost oder nach Schweiß?
Nein, also vielleicht habe ich heute Nacht ein bisschen geschwitzt, ja,
also weil ich mich so fieberig gefühlt habe, ja, aber also, dass ich jetzt jede Nacht total Schweiß gebadet aufwache,
nee, nee, die Zeiten sind vorbei.
Ich bin schon relativ lange im Klimakterium, also beziehungsweise, also,
dass ich keine, dass ich keine Periode mehr habe.
Und deswegen habe ich damals, hatte ich natürlich geschwitzt, aber jetzt nicht mehr.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Normalerweise schon, ja, weil ich auch viel arbeite und dann, ja, dann ist man auch müde,
aber letzte Nacht habe ich, weil es gut, nicht gut geschlafen, ja.
Mhm.
Ähm, haben Sie Probleme beim Schlucken?
Nein, da habe ich keine Probleme.
Hat Sie eher Partiz verändert?
Ja, also ja, zurzeit kann ich über Essen nicht mal nachdenken, ja.
Also, langfristig würde ich sagen, ist der Appetit immer geliebt, ich bin eigentlich immer ein guter Essener gewesen,
aber jetzt, also heute, seit gestern Abend, oh, nee, will ich überhaupt nicht aus Essen denken.
Okay.
Haben Sie bemerkt, inlässte Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Also mein Gewicht ist, glaube ich, immer gleich.
Immer gleich.
Ich rieche mich natürlich jetzt nicht jeden Tag, aber, also, dass ich da nun riesige Schwankungen habe,
oder so, das würde man ja an der Kleidung merken, nie, nie, da hat sich nichts getan.
Also, leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen, zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit.
Ja, ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck habe ich schon, ja, da nehme ich auch Tabletten dagegen ein, ja, ich nehme Bilok, zum 90, ja, da nehme ich ein Tablette.
Dann habe ich mal wieder Rückenschmerzen, weil ich eben viel arbeiten muss.
Und, was ich auch habe, das hat man schon, ja, vor sechs Jahren, ging das schon an, da hat man das festgestellt, ich habe in beiden Augen Grünster.
Grünster?
Da muss ich halt regelmäßig Augen tropfen nehmen, ne?
Wissen Sie weiche Augen tropfen und weiche Dosierung?
Oh, wie die heißen, das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
Aber ich, also ich muss in jedes Auge morgens und abends hier eintropfen rein, aber wie das heißt, weiß ich nicht.
Wie lange haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Oh, das hat man vor ein paar Jahren festgestellt, also bestimmt schon drei, vier Jahre.
Ja, drei, vier Jahre, ja.
Wie lange haben Sie Rückenschmerzen und dann nehmen Sie dagegen einen Megamanter?
Wenn ich viel arbeite, ja, also wir haben halt eine Landwirtschaft und da ist halt viel körperliche Arbeit und wenn wir viel gearbeitet haben, ja, dann tut mir schon mal der Rücken weh.
Alles klar.
Gib es noch an der Vorarlankung?
Also, ja, das wird Sie nicht interessieren, dass ich mal eine Blindermenzündung hatte als Kind, ja, da bin ich mal operiert worden und ja, dann hat jetzt die Frauenärztin hat festgestellt, dass ich kleine Millionaire habe in der Gebärmutter, die sollen halt beobachtet werden.
Alles klar.
War nun Sie schon mal in der Station in Krankenhaus?
Ja, damals als Kind, die Blindermoperation, ja, und dann hatte ich auch einen Arbeitsunfall und da ist das linke Handgelenk, ist ziemlich kompliziert gebrochen gewesen.
Da war ich auch kurzfristig im Krankenhaus, dass es operiert worden ist.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie regermäßig Medikamente an, außer Bruthochdruck Medikamente und Augen troffen?
Ne, sonst brauche ich eigentlich nichts, ne?
Nehmen Sie bei Bedarf Medikamente ein.
Ja, also wenn man mal so ganz dolle Kopfschmerzen hat oder so, dann nehme ich wo mal Aspirin oder aber eigentlich oder oder was, was ich bei Husten oder so, nimmt man mal Husten dar, aber also nicht das sich regelmäßig irgendwelche Medikamente einnehmen.
Und ich muss auch tatsächlich ein bisschen aufpassen, auf einige Tabletten bin ich auch allergisch.
Ich darf zum Beispiel so einige Antibiotika gar nicht nehmen.
Antibiotika.
Haben Sie noch andere Allergien oder Unfahrt-Rechlichkeit?
Ja, leider schon. Also ich bin allergisch auf Hausstau und dann eben auf Penicillin und Tetrazyklin, das darf ich beides nicht bekommen.
Dann reagiere ich allergisch, wenn ich Harsenüsse esse und ich habe auch eine Allergie im Frühling, wenn die Birken blühen, dann geht es mir schlecht, dann habe ich halt rähnende Augen und Schnupfen und ja, krieg ich nicht gut Luft.
Und letztendlich habe ich auch noch eine Jodallergie, ja.
Jod, eine Jodallergie.
Also ich muss schon ziemlich aufpassen, ja.
Rauchen Sie Frahander?
Nee, also geraucht habe ich noch nie.
Haben Sie früher geraucht?
Auch früher habe ich nicht geraucht, nee, nee.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also ich trinke schon regelmäßig Wein, ja.
Wie oft trinken Sie?
Also eigentlich jeden Tag so zwei Gläser bestimmt.
Zwei Gläser?
Das ist eine Routinefrage, bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich, nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nee, also mit Drogen, nee, nee, da habe ich keinen Kontakt.
Okay.
Gib es in Ihrer Familie bestimmte Erkrankungen?
Ja, gesund ist dann natürlich nicht alle.
Meine Mutter hat inzwischen eine schwere Alzheimer-Demenz,
das macht uns auch natürlich große Sorgen.
Und mein Vater hatte einen Herzinfarkt, der ist nicht alt geworden.
Und ja, dann habe ich noch einen Bruder,
der hat wahrscheinlich ein bisschen viel getrunken oder so,
der hat jedenfalls Leberprobleme, der sagt man, der hat eine Leberzeroose, ne?
Alles klar.
Haben Sie noch ein der Geschwister?
Nee, nee, also nur der Bruder.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, die gehen noch zur Schule, ja, die sind beide auch im Gymnasium
und leider will keiner von denen den Hof übernehmen, das macht uns große Sorgen.
Ja, mit der Landwirtschaft, das ist ein bisschen schwierig jetzt, ne?
Alles klar.
Haben Sie Haustiere?
Na ja, Haustiere haben wir schon.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob Sie Kühe und Schweine auch zu Haustieren zählen,
aber wir haben natürlich auch ein Hund und eine Katze, ja.
Und Hühner haben wir auch.
Ja, sehr schön.
Machen Sie gerne die Sport?
Schön wäre es, ja, aber bei der Arbeit habe ich eigentlich genug Sport
und ja, wenn ich dazu komme, fahre ich eigentlich gerne mit dem Fahrrad, ja.
Alles klar.
Das waren alle meine Fragen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, eigentlich, Sie haben mich ja so viel gemacht, ich habe Ihnen ja so viel erzählt.
Sie wissen mir alles über mich jetzt schon, ja.
Ja, also ich wüsste natürlich jetzt, was wir dagegen machen können
und ja, dass das nicht wieder kommt, ne?
Ich will es natürlich los werden, das Problem, so kann ich ja nicht arbeiten, ne?
Ja, ich verstehe, dass Ihre Sorge, aber machen Sie sie nicht,
Sie keine Sorgen.
Wir werden sofort körperliche Untersuchungen und
Laboparameter überprüfen.
Ach, okay.
Nein, werde ich weitere Schritte informieren.
Über weitere Schritte, hm?
Über.
Okay, gut, ja.
Und wo kann ich jetzt warten?
Ja, vielleicht wäre das schon gut, wenn ich dann jetzt mal etwas gegen die Schmerzen bekommen könnte.
Ich empfehle jetzt, eh, Ihnen in Krankenhaus bleiben.
Oh ja.
Ich habe es schon gemacht, weil wir sofort eine Untersuchung machen.
Und er braucht Ultraschall machen.
Ah ja, das kenne ich von den Tieren auch, ja.
Mhm.
Okay, also, wo kann ich jetzt warten?
Warten Sie draußen und...
Sie rufen mich auf, ja? Sie rufen mich auf, wenn es weitergeht, ja?
Keine Ahnung.
Sie rufen mich, Sie rufen nicht, wenn es weitergeht.
Ja.
Okay, gut.
Okay.
Mhm.
Das war alles.
Okay, ja.
Hast du jemanden auch zusätzliche Fragen?
Ja, ich möchte noch einige Fragen stellen.
Ja, gerne.
Ja, ich habe leider die alle Antworten nicht gut gehört, weil die meine Internetplanung mehrmals gebrochen ist.
Und seit wann haben Sie Schmerzen?
Das ist halt gestern Abend plötzlich.
Plötzlich angefangen.
Ja, genau.
Und Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie mehrmals erbrochen haben.
Mhm.
Und haben Sie Blut im Erbrochenen gesehen?
Ja, hat Sie bestätigt, ja.
Okay.
Und können Sie bitte die Schmerzen nochmal genau beschreiben?
Wie Götelformige?
Und Sie haben schon gesagt, in den Rücken und Schultern ausstrahlen.
Da haben Sie die rechte Schulter und die in den Rücken.
Und Sie sind im Oberbauchrecht.
Und es sind wellenförmige Schmerzen.
Und es kramft sich alles zusammen.
Ach so.
Und stehen die Schmerzen immer da?
Oder in kurzerseits Raum die Schmerzen verschwunden?
Nein, so richtig.
Das tut die ganze Zeit weh.
Es macht so Wellen, ja.
wird, aber eigentlich so ganz weg sind die Schmerzen nicht. Ist ihnen gerade
schwindelig oder haben sie schon das Bewusstsein verloren? Nein, nein, es ist
schwindelig, war mir nicht und und und Bewusstsein habe ich auch nicht verloren.
Nein, nein. Und noch eine Frage. Erleben Sie diese Beschwerden zum
ersten mal oder sind ihnen schon die Magen dann Erkrankungen bekannt? Ja, also ich habe
da schon seit längerer Zeit, das habe ich auch der der Ärztin schon gesagt, wenn ich
fettiges Essen gegessen habe, dann hat der Bauch schon immer mal wieder
gezwickt und dann habe ich immer die Schmerzen.
Die Schmerzen hat sich halt, oder ohne Therapie? Ja, das ist dann wieder besser
geworden, ja. Und das war auch nicht so heftig wie jetzt.
Danke schön. Gerne. Hat jemand noch weitere Fragen?
Sehr geehrte Frau Oberastin, ich möchte Ihnen heute unseren neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Was? Vorstellen? Vorstellen.
Frau Handorf ist ein 50-jähriger Patientin, die sich wegen seit gestern Abend
plötzlich aufgetreten hat, krampfartig rechtzeitig mit Rücken und Schulterstrahlen,
Abdominalgie bei uns vorstellte. Die Patient berichtet, dass ihre Fieber 38
Centigrate ist, die Patient klagt über drei oder vier Mal,
Neuzia.
Emesis?
Emesis, Emesis, hematemesis.
Diese Schmerzen sind nach dem Essen schlimm geworden.
Die Patienten sagten, dass gestern Kartoffeln und Fettereisen gegessen hat.
Die Fragen nach Pyrosis, Dispepsi wurden verneint.
Sie haben seit 5 Jahren eine antipartensiv Medikamente mit 2,5 mg morgens gegessen.
Sie haben seit 5 Jahren eine Rückenschmerzen und seit 6 Jahren Glokom.
Sie haben gegen das Glokom benutzt, sie regelmäßig Augen trocken.
Die Patienten wurden gegen Epandysitis operiert.
Sie haben sich in der Uterus begonnen.
Die Patienten reagiert auf, Hausstab, Milben, Tetrasiklin, Penicillin, Hazelnüsse,
Birken und Fröhlich-Pollen, und Jodalargie.
Sie haben die linkseitige Handgelenken geprochen.
Sie haben die Handgelenken in der Faktus.
Sie haben die Handgelenken in der Landwirtschaft gearbeitet.
Sie haben viele Hauptstiere, Küle und Katze.
Sie machen regelmäßig Sport, z.B. Fahrradfahren.
Sie haben die Analyse auf, Pancreatitis, Alsthythin, Diagnose,
Polycystitis oder Maginkarsnone in Betra.
Ich höre Abdomen ab.
Ich zeige Abdomen.
Ich gebe Ihnen ein Hinweis. Die Patientin hat gesagt, sie hat dunklen Urin.
Sie hat gesagt, sie hat dunklen Urin.
Es kam noch einige Hinweise.
Es kam noch einige Einblendungen von den Kollegen.
Was ist die Medikation oder die Therapie?
Ich würde empfehlen, therapeutisch, stationale Aufnahme und Alkoholkarenz.
Das ist eine Erweiterung.
Was kriegt ihr gegen die Schmerzen?
Schmerzmittel.
Was kriegt ihr gegen die Entzündung?
Gut, dass ich darauf denke.
Schauen Sie mal, was bei Ihren Untersuchungen rauskommt.
Sie laden dich daneben.
Sie haben die Schmerzgürtel für die Pankreatitis nicht.
Es ist ein Stein.
Sie hat nicht gesagt, dass der Schmerz gürtelförmig ist.
Sie hat gesagt, der Schmerz ist im Oberbauch und strahlt in die Schulter und in den Rücken aus.
Sie hat nicht gesagt, dass der Kollege nicht gürtelförmig ist.
Sie hat gesagt, nach Fettigem Essen kann das in jedem Fall sein.
Sie hat nicht gefragt, ob ihr eine Gelb-Ferbung aufgefallen ist.
Sie hat gesagt, meine Augen sehen komisch gelb aus.
Da sind schon Zeichen, die für den Inktorus sprechen.
Die Frau bringt die klassischen Risikofaktoren für die Geilensteine.
Sie haben die 6F für das Risiko für die Geilenerkrankung.
Frau Kollegin, Sie wissen diese Frage.
Sie können antworten, wie sind die typische Symptome für die Geilenblase stein 6F?
Sie wissen alle, selbst ich weiß das.
Sie ist übergewichtig, sie ist blond, sie ist weiblich und sie hat Kinder.
Was ist die klassische Untersuchung für die Geilensteine?
Sie wissen alle, wie es steht.
Entoskopische Retrograde, Kolangio Pancreaticografie.
Ich sage Ihnen etwas zur Sprache.
Sie haben sich viele Sachen überlegt für die Fragen.
Im Fragenkataloge war es okay.
Wenn ich das nicht mache, dann ist mir aufgefallen.
Schwierig ist, wenn die Leute etwas nachfragen.
Natürlich ist es schwieriger, das Arztgespräch zu führen, als die Anamese zu machen.
Sie haben gesagt, sehr geehrte Frau Oberärztin.
Ich habe gerade eine Patientin gesehen.
Sie haben das richtig gut angefangen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass sie übergewichtige Patientinnen unterbringen.
Ich schreibe in Arztbrief, ich gebe ihnen groß und ich spreche ihnen nicht.
Sie haben gesagt, dass sie überwärtschmerzen.
Sie haben sehr schön das gemacht und haben den Genitiv genommen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass die Schmerzen nach dem Essen schlimmer geworden sind.
Sie haben gesagt, dass sie überwärtschmerzen.
Sie haben das zusammengebischt.
Sie haben gefragt, ob es in ihrer Familie Erkrankungen gibt.
Sie haben überhört.
Sie haben gesagt, dass sie überwärtschmerzen.
Dr. Kruppi, vielen Dank für die Ergänzung.
Wir sehen uns, wenn Sie mögen, übermorgen?
Ja, übermorgen. Wir haben noch eine Kandidatin für Übung.
Wir freuen uns mit Ihnen noch mal zu treffen, wenn Sie seid haben.
Ich habe Zeit, ja. Eigentlich halte ich mit Dienstab und dann.
Ich könnte für Vatergesundheits- oder Vaterfamilien eine Möglichkeit erlitten.
Das könnte man so formulieren.
Genau. Das ist ein Unterschied, ob ich sage, jemand leidet an etwas oder er hat etwas erlitten.
Das eine dauert noch an. Das ist gegenwahrt und dauert immer noch an.
Und er hat erlitten ist in der Vergangenheit.
Das ist ein Punktereignis.
Ein Infarkt ist ein Punktereignis.
Oder eine OP.
Ich werde nicht monatelang operiert, sondern werde einmal operiert.
Dann ist alles gut, wenn es keine Komplikationen gibt.
Wenn ich unter der OP einen Schlaganfall bekomme, habe ich Pech gehabt.
Dann kann ich sagen, die Patientin hatte im Rahmen einer Karottesoperation ein Apoplex.
Entweder stirbt sie daran oder erholt sich, hat Glück und keine bleibenden Schäden.
Oder sie hat den Apoplex erlitten und hat Vollgeschehen.
Und leidet nach wie vor unter einer Hemiplegie oder Sprachstörung oder whatever.
Aber wir müssen unterscheiden zwischen dem Punktereignis, das eine OP ist
und eine Erkrankung, die lange andauert.
Mein Diabetes werde ich nicht los oder mein Bluthochdruck, im Zweifelsfall auch nicht.
Das ist kein Punktereignis, das hat man nur an irgendeinem Zeitpunkt festgestellt.
Das weiß ich seit so und so vielen Jahren und seitdem nehme ich meine Medikamente.
Aber das ist das vor und seit, also vor zehn Jahren oder seit zehn Jahren.
Das ist der Unterschied.
Oder vor fünf Jahren und seit fünf Jahren.
Vor fünf Jahren bin ich operiert worden oder hat man etwas festgestellt
und seit fünf Jahren leide ich an der Erkrankung.
Wir müssen uns den Zeitstrahl vorstellen und das eine ist ein Punkt auf dem Zeitstrahl
und das andere ist eine Dauer auf dem Zeitstrahl.
Das ist der Unterschied.
Deutisch schwierig, ich weiß es.
Ja, alles klar.
Vielen Dank. Sie beschreiben sehr ausführlich und sehr detailliert.
Aber können Sie das nachvollziehen?
Ja, ja, ja, genau. Vielen, vielen Dank.
Gerne.